challenge that we needed to get out
immediately the cares act
helped to mitigate circumstances for
people in terms of wage replacement
across the country it is clear that the
six hundred dollars
that were added to the
weekly unemployment benefit
has offered i know some uh
conflict but but here's the reality of
it the reality
is you can't quit your job to get an
extra six hundred dollars
a week but secondly knowing
that the pandemic with 30 million
americans
having filed for unemployment insurance
that the contagion
of the health care system would make its
way into the contagion of the economic
system and people would have trouble
paying their rents and paying their
mortgages that's what this was about
and the wage replacement issue along
with the
extra six hundred dollars has gone a
long way toward ameliorating
some of that that pressure
the other side knew this was coming they
knew that
eventually despite the procrastination
the argument that they were waiting to
see how this would play out
now brings us to the eve of an economic
catastrophe
if unemployment insurance is not
extended
you can see that uh right now that
there's great uncertainty that confronts
the american system
again a record number of coveted cases
the resurgence of the pandemic of the
reser the resurgence
of the virus is again causing great
economic uncertainty
it's linked to child care it's linked to
a chaotic system of
how states deliver unemployment
compensation
but what is important to remember is to
this moment
the united states senate has refused to
act
complacency would be the worst strategy
to adopt
right now i think of all the issues that
we
were able to put together in the cares
act including the retention tax credit
unemployment insurance aid for our
hospitals
what was really the most successful
endeavor was unemployment insurance
largely because it addressed the issue
of liquidity in the system
and because people need the sustenance
of day-to-day
life it also helped to create consumer
demand
those were the important considerations
we can't lose
the momentum that we developed in the
cares act by not getting immediately
to the heroes act they can't say that
they haven't had time to vet this
two months and 10 days they've had to go
through this
the evidence was overwhelming about the
pandemic
it wasn't getting better it
reached the ceiling for a while began to
slow down
but i would remind all that the governor
of connecticut has taken a different
position today the governor of
massachusetts has taken a different
position now
upon out-of-state visitors and this is
part of where we find ourselves whether
it's in california texas
or florida the truth is that the
recovery is going to be slow
largely because we're still in the
stages of stability and relief
so i think the unemployment insurance
issue is
not only compelling it's overwhelming
and
chairman davis has had a great deal to
do with this
uh he has said time and again during our
get-togethers our zoom calls
he believes that this is one of the most
important things that we did
and he's really made a big contribution
through the subcommittee that helped to
write this
chairman danny davis
thank you chairman neal you know these
past months have demonstrated
with unblinking charity the impact of
systemic racism
on every aspect of our society
i'm not going to miss words a republican
failure to continue the 600
a week federal unemployment supplement
would represent a racially
discriminatory
action period anywhere you cut it
any way you look at it african americans
and latinos make up a disproportionate
share
of essential workers of those
hospitalized
by the virus of those dying from the
virus
and of those facing evictions
to just simply stay in their homes
we cannot allow republicans to take a
colorblind position
on who is harmed by cutting off the 600
supplement for unemployed workers
unemployed individuals don't work
because they can't work they can't work
because
it's dangerous for them to work
they can't work because there is no work
and they can't work because there's no
child
care for them no place to take their
children
the house passed an extension of the 600
back
in may and the senate republicans and
president
have yet to act while millions of
americans
teeter on the edge wondering what's
going to happen
to them next will they be able to make
it through the next week
through the next month i reject the idea
that we could let the 600
supplement expire and just give
workers some help after the fact
one thing i know is that retroactive
benefits are not the same
you can't eat retroactivity
you can't afford medicine retroactively
businesses can't survive
retroactively now the republicans have
decided to push an approach that the
administration's
own labor department rejected is
unworkable so if the republican plan
can't work then the stock reality
is that the republican plan remains
cutting off the 600 dollars
what kind of leader punishes unemployed
workers
in the midst of a crisis the harm to
families and businesses is not
theoretical in the last recession we let
emergency unemployment benefits laps
and the harm to individuals and
retailers was immediate
and substantial in illinois
if republicans let the 600 expire
the average benefit will be cut
by 63 percent hardworking americans
deserve
relief we must protect workers and
families
we must do it now there's no
time to wait there's no time left
now is the time and we must
act immediately now i'd like to present
representative
kieldee from michigan
thank you chairman davis and to speaker
pelosi
chairman neal um joined by
mr evans ms chu both of the ways and
means committee appreciate
all your efforts we're here today with
one message for the president
and for the senate majority leader mr
mcconnell do your job
millions of americans are at risk of
losing everything that they've worked
for
and the only thing holding them together
has been this unemployment benefit and
the only thing
that prevents them from keeping it is
the inaction of this president
and of the united states senate coven 19
is simultaneously an economic crisis
and a health crisis 140 000 americans
have lost their lives
40 million american workers have lost
their jobs these simultaneous crises are
far
from over yesterday for the 18th week in
a row over a million people
filed for unemployment benefits our
unemployment rate nationally is over
11 worse than the great
recession and in my home state
it's one of the hardest hit states two
million michiganders
have lost their jobs we have passed
legislation
we're not just having a conversation
we're legislating
someone once told me a long time ago you
can't fund a conversation
we passed a bill that protects these
important
these important benefits and in addition
to that provides other critical support
for testing for frontline workers for
state and local governments for schools
and extends that 600 a week benefit for
months
republicans have failed to act they know
everything they need to know to make a
decision
on this question but the heroes act
sits on mitch mcconnell's desk gathering
dust
why isn't there any empathy from these
republicans
millions of americans are about to lose
everything that they've worked for
and not be able to put food on the table
not to be able to take care of their
families
and the senate republicans are literally
dining on alligator sausage
and crab bisque while americans are
trying to figure out how they're going
to put food on their own tables
because of their inaction we now find
ourselves
staring down tomorrow's deadline where
americans will stop getting that
essential lifeline this pandemic is not
over this is no
time to tell the american people you're
on your own
so even as we begin to open reopen parts
of the economy in some cases obviously
too quickly but even when
the economy does begin to reestablish
itself
the jobs won't come back as fast as they
were lost unemployment will still be a
significant problem
the highest levels we've seen since and
now
eclipsing the levels of the great
recession without this action 25 million
americans
again could lose everything that they've
worked their lives
to create every one of these dollars
matters
to these families and as chairman neil
said this is not just about
supporting those families but this
supports the american economy
imagine taking away this lifeline it not
only put those families in jeopardy
but it takes significant spending power
out of the economy
without this unemployment benefit
unemployment goes
up in this country and the problem gets
worse
i've heard from thousands of my
constituents we were chatting
before coming out here all of us for the
most part the majority
of the calls we get have to do with
unemployment benefits and i just want to
i just want to mention a couple of these
folks rick from bay city michigan wrote
to me to say quote
please vote to extend the 600
unemployment
it's been a much needed lifeline it
helps with basic needs like
housing and medicine we nearly lost our
home and everything we do not know
what we are going to do without that
extra 600 stopping these payments seems
cruel
we're barely hanging on jeffrey from
saginaw wrote to me
basically the same story he said i'm
still making far less than i did but i'm
at least
able to get by crystal from burton said
i
fear my children and i are going to be
left homeless and without food
i just don't know what what else we'd do
these are the stakes
these are the stakes this is about real
american lives that are going to be
affected
permanently do we want to create the
first generation of another round of
multiple generation
poverty no we don't we have acted
the leader in this effort and all of our
efforts
has been our leader the speaker and she
has been just uh
just dogging in her determination to get
this done so it's my pleasure to bring
forward our leader the speaker speaker
pelosi thank you very much
thank you mr kildee uh thank you
chairman neal thank you
chairman davis uh thank you all for
focusing on this very central issue
an issue that goes to the heart of the
kitchen table concerns of america's
working families we can talk about a
number of things
time everything is about time the time
it has taken for the administration to
recognize
uh that you should wear a mask the time
it took
98 days just under about 100 days
to reach 1 million people infected in
the united states
half that time to reach 2 million 43
days
27 days to reach 3 million people
16 days to reach 4 million
terrible terrible and a congresswoman
chew
as say mr chairman davis thank you
congressman evans
mr kildee and mr chairman neil for
bringing us here we we you know we keep
saying you want to open the schools you
want to open
the economy defeat this virus
and yet and yet and yet delay
distortion denial has taken us to a
place where we have four million people
and there are many other concerns that
we have of state and local government
having to fire
people and the list is a long one of
concerns that we're trying to address
that mr davis
rightly calls really it injustices
in how they disproportionately impact
communities of color
and the rest but right now we are
focusing on this
one subject the extension
of the unemployment insurance benefit
this
is central to the well-being of
america's family
what do the republicans and the white
house
have against working families in our
country
that they would begrudge them six
hundred dollars
of well absolutely necessary sustenance
this is there are other things in here
too it's about paying the rent
and it's about buying food so with this
package we have people
on the verge of eviction we have
millions of
children starving food insecure in
america
we need the on the food stamps and the
rest
and they resent that we had legislation
in the heroes act and independently to
help with
rent so that people are not evicted and
we have
this money and the unemployment benefit
so i thank the members of the ways and
means committee for always recognizing
always recognizing the connection
between our policy
and the health and livelihood the lives
and livelihood
of america's working families
as again as mr kildee said
we hear calls all the time people
crying on the phone crying on tv crying
they're in pain they're
it's about their dignity and how they
meet the needs of their
children and why
and why because the republicans are
derelict in their duty
taking off for the weekend instead of
being ready all these months
without preparing something to begin
with when we had our offer they make
their offer
now two months and and eight ten days
have gone by
and where are they and where is their
offer which earlier this week they said
we would see in 24 or 48
hours they're in disarray and their
disarray
is causing great great damage to
america's working families
this is an alarm that needs to be
sounded as loudly as possible
about what are we doing here if we're
not
addressing the needs of people who've
lost their jobs
through no fault of their own and as mr
davis said
they tell them to go to work go to work
you're an essential worker you must go
to work
and when you go to work and there are no
protections you have no recourse
and if you don't go to work because
you're afraid that you're going to bring
some
the the uh infection home to your
children
you don't get unemployment insurance but
mr
mr neal the distinguished chairman he
has always been there for the people
who need it the most as
counter by the republicans who
are there for people who have the most
so when they talk about six hundred
dollars i want to review the fact that
they put two trillion dollars onto the
national debt
to give a tax break to the wealth 83
percent of the benefits
to the top one percent i'll close
prayerfully
quoting saint augustine some of you have
heard me say this almost every day
saint augustine 1700 years ago
he said any government that is not
formed
to promote justice is just a bunch
of thieves let's use our time
to remove all doubt that we're going to
do the right thing
by the american people so they can meet
the needs of their families
everybody wants to talk about being
family friendly
let's not squawk about six hundred
dollars with that i yield back to the
distinguished chair of the committee
will you pass a bill to invoke a
short-term
renewal of these benefits so that they
don't lapse for americans
i will tell you this the ways of mean
committee intends next week to hold a
hearing on unemployment insurance
yeah let me just say this we have we
have food stamps in there and they're
like what you want more money for food
stamps
we have housing in there what you want
money for housing
we have this benefit in there there is
i would be very much averse to
separating this out and lose all
leverage
for all meeting all of the other needs
it's a fraudulent
tactic and with all due respect to you
an unworthy question when it comes to
meeting the needs of america's working
families
but we have i'm glad you're having the
hearing to keep the spotlight on it
what is the point of put they could have
done they could have
done their job as you said do your job
i mean this is dereliction of duty
and our responsibility the american
people and now we you're saying why
don't you just bail them out
so they can ignore all the needs that we
have for testing
all the needs we have are state and
local government all the needs we have
for food security all the needs we have
for osha benefit
that is in the bill all the needs that
we have uh for
vote by mail and other priorities that
we have
that are about justice
are you considering extending these
benefits for a month or two while you
continue to negotiate
the point being the republicans have
every bit of information they need to
make a decision
legislation if you go through it with
the retention tax credit and all
it's really a good piece of legislative
work it's a it's a tactic
in order not to honor our other
responsibilities
it will not be a party to their tactics
senate republicans want to keep their
bills in a trillion dollars
given money for education
more money for tpp etc when you bring in
the unemployment insurance benefit of
another 600
do you think it is possible to extend
extend
that benefit at that level and keep a
bill within a trillion dollars
what we said to the republican i'm going
to tell you something
this is deadly serious a house is
burning down
in terms of the economic security of
america's families
and these people are sitting wherever
they may be
this weekend so when you talk about well
they want to do a trillion dollars so
how can we do
six hundred dollars for those in the
most need
when when they got other things they
want to do that's why chuck and i the
distinguished leader and i said to them
put your bill on paper
put your bill on paper and then we'll
see
what you have included and what you have
left out
and then the american people will see
what you have included
and what you have left out but i'm
telling you
you can't have any more patience you
know
it's a wonderful thing i read it's
amazing how much patience people can
have
with other people suffering well we
don't have that patience
on our side of the aisle and so for them
to say a trillion dollars
when they spent two trillion dollars to
give a tax cut to the richest people in
america eighty-three percent of the
benefits
to the top one percentage and they
borrowed it they
heaped it on the backs of our children
for future generations so
uh let us see what their trillion
dollars gets them
and what are they excluding they have
nothing for state and local
where people are working
healthcare professionals food suppliers
transit workers teachers teachers
teachers sanitation
people who make a system run
over a million and a half of them have
been fired already because
of the needs of a coronavirus the
expenses of coronavirus
and the revenue lost because of corona
take that out
let those people go okay so now they
don't have jobs
they probably have to go on unemployment
right
so what money have they saved and then
we have testing testing testing
they shut down their cafeteria the
minute somebody got a
uh infected in the uh
white house complex they shut it down
they're testing and tracing
why can't they put that money there for
the states in a substantial way with a
strategic plan
to do that so what money do they have
there for that
then we have the money for for uh rental
assistance and mortgage
forbearance and
food stamps as i keep saying the one
thing i just can't understand is how
they could even show their faces by
saying
food stamps you want more money for food
stamps why would we
why would we do that well because people
are hungry
in america doesn't that motivate you so
a trillion dollars that
our bill 3.4 mean and lean
it's everything we need it's nothing
extra
so let's see where their trillion dollar
takes them
and not have them use that as a reason
why they can't give
america's working families six six
hundred dollars
don't get me started on that six hundred
dollars you know i think it's important
it's important to note though even if
somehow
even if somehow the republicans can't
conjure some empathy
for these families which is hard to
comprehend
they ought to at least be able to
comprehend the fact that to the extent
that this economy has been barely held
together
it's because these families have had
this unemployment benefit
and the spending power to go down to the
corner grocery store
and to pay their rent and to take care
of their families that money
goes directly into the u.s economy so
even if they can't figure out a way to
have sympathy and empathy
for the families that would be hurt and
harmed so much by this
they ought to at least enroll in an
entry-level economics class and
understand if you take that money out of
the economy
this whole house of cards is going to
collapse and that's why they need to act
now
[Music]
thank you on the issue of price tag um
the heroes act passed two months ago
plus and conditions have changed on the
ground obviously more money
that's that was my question is 3.4
enough given that a lot of
a lot of parts of the country are
suffering more than there were two
months ago
and where would where would that be i
know you've mentioned that education
could you
if i may use your question but to pivot
from what mr kelde was saying
we are a consumer economy our economy it
grows and succeeds and is strengthened
by the comp the consumer confidence that
is there
they should know that at the same time
as they are spending
trillions of dollars to bolster the
stock market
so it has a floor and that's not a bad
thing
we should be spending trillions of
dollars to have a floor
for america's working families because
it's the right thing to do
but it's also the most a pragmatic thing
to do
in order where you put money into
businesses if there's
you ain't got no customers it's no use
having money to pay the rent and the
staff if you want if there's no business
so this money
is spent it's necessary needed it's
spent
it injects demand into the economy and
it creates
jobs so i just wanted to go back to your
point
okay on education for example we need
much more money we had a hundred billion
dollars in for education
we all we we also knew that that wasn't
really quite enough
but we were trying to be lean and mean
with the budget
and um um they came in with 105 this
week and they said well you have 500
but of course you have to see where they
want to spend that money
but we probably need double that much uh
at least double that much for education
for one thing
but by and large um we have we're
we're in pretty good shape with what we
have in the budget if we could spend it
now now they want to do
zero for state and local really tell it
to the governors and mayors
across county executives across the
country
we have to have that money they're not
going to be at a trillion dollars and if
you see their trillion dollar list
it's really going to be a big
embarrassment to the republican party
to see who they cut out and who they
include and how they were willing to
spend double that
for a tax cut for their rich friends
anybody else
i heard you say
um directed to you but anybody can
answer and i'm following up on nancy's
question
i heard you say no multiple times but
isn't this issue on a different level in
the sense that it is immediate it is
going to expire and that some of the
other things while
also important uh funding for elections
and funding for education isn't going to
have the the effect that
mr kildee has described his constituents
are worried about
well if you were going to be evicted at
the end of this month you might not
think the same way
if you were crying because you couldn't
put food on the table for your children
you might be thinking a different way
that's why we have to have
these actually a safety net for the
capitalist system everybody says
safety network it's a capitalist system
safety net
so that they can wheel and deal and free
wing and then in the cycle of things
when people need help there's a safety
net
for the capitalist system so if we're
going to have a capital system which i
fully support and want to strengthen we
strengthen it
by making removing all doubt
that when things go one way or another
people are not going to have to explain
to their children why they don't have
food on the
on the table so this is very important
so you want to have you want to see how
many people will be on the street being
evicted because they
cannot pay the rent
and then they can't pay the rent
exponentially because they're not
getting the 600
i'm just going to lighten up the mood
here
i'm going to tell you this all right
carl reiner great you know you're all
too young to know but he was a great
comedian
right and his son rob reiner meathead
maybe you're too young for that
anyway he died a great comedian in his
90s 98 years old
so i called his son rob
who is a comedian too i called rob
rob rob darling
this is nancy pelosi i'm calling to wish
you and michelle
my condolences i'm so sad your father
was so funny and so wonderful i had the
occasion to hear him
remember this man says i think you have
the wrong
number
i said really i'm so sorry i thought
this was rob reiner's he said well you
know i know who carl reiner is and i rob
runners
but i think you have the wrong number i
said well i'm so sorry
whether i talk to my staff about this
and he says but i'm so glad you called
me
i have one question for you i said what
is that
he said am i going to get my 600 dollars
i'm very proud of her i thought it was
great i we're daughters
two great two granddaughters and uh i
thought she was just great
it was you know what she said is what we
all know
a president of the united states who
gives license to people to speak that
way
who are at ease with that kind of
disrespect
condescension and the rest and in
keeping what the president was saying
about his fear-mongering for
a woman who lived in suburbia and how he
treated that fear-mongering
discrimination disrespect
condescension i was very proud of her
thank you all very much
oh
thank you
okay
networking
yes
be friends
was
thank you